okay today I'm going to talk to you
about the greenhouse effect we're going
to see what the greenhouse effect is and
how humans are impacting the greenhouse
effect okay so first of all we need to
know exactly what the greenhouse effect
is so here we have the earth and I've
just up here doing a little diagram the
Sun now this obviously is not to scale
at all so the Sun emits electromagnetic
radiation and it travels towards the
earth like this now around the Earth we
actually have a layer of gases called
the atmosphere so the layer of gases go
all around the earth like this now
within the atmosphere we obviously have
oxygen we have nitrogen but we also have
some gases that referred to as
greenhouse gases and the main greenhouse
gases are carbon dioxide water vapor and
methane but the most significant one
that we're looking at today and focusing
on is carbon dioxide because we're going
to see the role of carbon dioxide now
when the electromagnetic radiation hits
the earth we have a couple of different
options some of it is absorbed by the
earth some of it is real it it out into
space and some of it is real it'ld as
infrared radiation in fact any of this
any of these in red shows the infrared
radiation which is Rio mitad from the
surface of the earth now infrared
radiation is basically infrared
radiation is all about heat
so some of the infrared radiation is
absorbed that means taken in by the
greenhouse gases some of it also is
reflected back towards the surface of
the earth by the greenhouse gases as
well so this phenomenon here causes an
increase in the temperature around the
globe and this is the greenhouse effect
it's these gases absorbing the infrared
radiation which is really from the
surface of the earth and reflecting some
of that infrared radiation back towards
the surface of the earth now the
greenhouse effect is important if there
were no greenhouse gases whatsoever the
temperature of the earth would be around
minus 18 degree C and that would be a
big problem because it wouldn't be able
to sustain life so as a result it's
really really important that we have
some degree of greenhouse effect however
here is the big problem when it comes to
the greenhouse effect if I do a quick
little graph at the bottom against the
concentration of co2 in the atmosphere
over the last few hundred years since
the Industrial Revolution the
concentration of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere has exponentially increased
now this is due to a massive increase of
population around the world people using
cars and planes and any other form of
transport that release carbon dioxide
that burn fuels the burning of fossil
fuels as well to produce our energy also
the cutting down of trees so
deforestation
because remember trees remove carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere through the
process of photosynthesis so all of
these different things that people are
doing and because there's been such a
big
population the concentration of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere has massively
increased so we don't just have this
regular level of greenhouse gases we
have much much more
so human humans have caused an enormous
increase in greenhouse gases
particularly co2 so what does that mean
well what that means is less of that
infrared radiation is being emitted back
into space more of that infrared
radiation is being absorbed by the
greenhouse gases and more of it is being
reflected back to the surface of the
earth because we've got a higher
concentration of these greenhouse gases
particularly co2 as a result we have
something which is referred to as the
enhanced greenhouse effect it basically
means that human intervention has caused
more of this greenhouse effect to occur
them than necessary and it's causing a
rise in global temperature so the
temperatures across the whole world are
increasing in order to find out a little
bit more about what the problems are
with the enhanced greenhouse effect
please watch the video that I've made
about climate change so guys that's
basically the greenhouse effect and the
problems caused by humans releasing more
carbon dioxide thank you